un trou béant orne le plafond l'échelle
et cassé des chutes de plaques de plâtre
entoure le pigeonnier le symbole de la
ferme royal de rambouillet la fondation
du patrimoine lance une levée de fonds
pour elle ce bâtiment a une mémoire
historique crucial parce que c'est un
élément emblématique de cette ferme
quand on a constitué cette ferme au
xviiie siècle fermes modèles voulue par
par louis saez
on a fait des bâtiments d'élevage
d'exploitation mais le pigeonnier qui
était un élément non seulement décoratif
mais de pouvoir de symboles du pouvoir
et donc c'est assez le symbole si vous
voulez de l'importance politique que
pouvait avoir cette ferme
trois cent mille euros une somme que la
fondation veut rassembler pour subvenir
aux besoins du bâtiment fermé au public
depuis la fin des années 90 les
dirigeants de la bergerie ont des
projets plein la tête pour ce colombier
une fois restauré ce prisonnier d'abord
être réouvert au public parce que pour
l'instant on peut pas l'ouvrir au public
il est pas en état ensuite on espère
pouvoir il
y faire des activités d animation des
événements culturels
on verra des expositions on peut faire
des expositions photos on peut faire des
expositions tables on peut également
faire une petite résidence d'artistes il
ya plein d'idées pour pour valoriser ce
monument une fois qu'il sera restaurée
au moins cinq mois de travaux seront
nécessaires une fois les fonds récoltés
ce qui ne devrait pas affecter les
visiteurs ni les pensionnaires de la
bergerie